on today's show we have a special theme
we're all tired of talking about it
we're tired of listening to it
but every one of us is being affected by
kova 19 in some way
so on today's show i answer your calls
your letters your questions
about how cove is affecting you your
relationships your family everything
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what up what up this is john with
the dr john dolone show
the show we named after me because why
not
right i guess i'm the only person in
here this is the covid
theme show you're sick of it i'm sick of
it but here's the reality
we're all dealing with fallout from
kovid whether it's relationships or
work or what we're gonna do next or
burnout or fried we're cooked
so we're gonna take a series of calls
about how folks are wrestling with
covet and by the way this is the third
time to
to do this intro here is a little inside
baseball
we shoot these intros and we go from
camera to camera to k
the first time we were shooting this
little fancy intro the background got
all screwed up because zach's elbow
leaned on some weird button then the
second time
james was singing a song and got all
teary and that got screwed up
and while we're here james number one i
can see you flexing back there but
but these earphones man i asked james
hey uh you can i don't know partner with
bows or other fancy places or you can
want to run to walgreens
and you can run to any shop on any
corner in america and get
headphones like this and when you do
that
sometimes they sound like that movie
alien versus predator when they're
fighting that's what it sounds like in
this ear so i took it out and then i was
trying to look like eddie vedder it
didn't work out it's just a whole
shenanigan so this is part three
thanks for joining us on the show that i
so vainly named after myself
i had all these other awesome names and
this is the one we stuck with so it is
what it is
but on this show we talk about your life
your mental health challenges your
relationships
everything that's going on in the world
around
you we walk alongside one another trying
to figure out what we can do
next i i gotta say it man
we have a packed house out here in the
studio audience
we got two we got two this is a 200
increase of what it was yesterday and
the day before so that's exciting
there's two people in the back
work here they have to be here just
that's like their job
but you two joined us because man
the lockdown is getting to you guys huh
you realize wow this is it this is what
we got so
i appreciate y'all coming to hang out
you could have gone to the zoo
you could have gone to any of the cool
things down in nashville
so um i gotta
shout you guys out but i also have to
shout this out
i got a letter so i don't i don't ever
know if i can say people's names on
on this show without asking them and so
i'm not asking so i'm just going to say
i got a letter
from louisville kentucky and here's the
card if you're watching this on youtube
it's a card it just says thank you and
it's really kind
and inside i opened it up and i gasped
because i stay this it's a couple
and they sent it to me and
inside this nice card that they wrote
just saying hey they like the show and
and really kind stuff
they sent four garbage pail kids
and if you're a hundred like me and you
remember back in the day
they were these these cards that are
super
not cool i mean like they are
um not good they're really not good man
like how this didn't get cancelled
instantly i guess they didn't have that
back then but
man but when you're a kid
you would get baseball cards and then
you would also try to get garbage spill
kit cards
and they were super offensive and super
not pc
and i haven't seen these in 30 year
three decades maybe
for i don't i these were not even in my
head and then
suddenly this awesome family says and i
quote
we think you think these were funny we
think that you think
that these would be funny to which i was
like i kind of think they're funny
they're super disrespectful and rude but
they're pretty funny
i'm so grateful that y'all reached out
this is the most creative gift i've
received since i worked here and this is
awesome so i just want to say thank you
for sending me old
rude baseball cards that aren't even
baseball cards how would you call these
i don't know but i'm shocked that you i
always make fun of you for saying
don't send me your cards and letters
like no one people send me cards and
letters a card in a letter it's amazing
i think they realize that i don't
understand how electronic communication
works too well so they actually go to
the old post office
and i'm super grateful so you know who
you are if you see me garbage bill kids
thank you for making my whole week
better it's awesome so we got a packed
show today and we've got a
like a a rip rolling studio audience
today so let's get right to the phones
let's go to nessa in salt lake city utah
nessa what's going on how can i help hey
thank you for taking my call
thank you so much for calling hey by the
way before we get going have you ever
heard of garbage pail kids
no all right you weren't that was a
really lovely way of saying you're a
super old man
and you're kind of creeping me out so i
called you to talk about something else
so sorry about that i'll look him up
hey for sure don't for sure don't
they will not enliven your life in any
way but that's all good okay so what's
going on how can i help
yeah so pretty much um coveted
family problems so um i had a baby last
year
in july and my husband and i decided
that we were going to kind of follow cdc
guidelines and do everything that we
could to keep
our new baby safe during a pandemic okay
and it caused a lot of attention on his
side of the family
and it started out with passive
aggressive comments
and then all the way up to his dad
messaging him uh saying bad things about
me
and now they are trying to manipulate
and gaslight the situation
um and say things like they're not you
know they'll just wait and see his
their great their grandson by the time
he's 21 and things like that
hey hey listen because they're not my
family
when adults act like four-year-olds and
through a four-year-old temper tantrums
i love it
now if this was happening at my house it
would not be funny so
i'm i am i'm laughing
at you not with you right but no no no i
get it i need you to know
oh gosh so you do
anyway so how can i help
man how can i i'm basically
these conversations now like my
relationship with them is
extremely strained i tried to sit down
with them and have a face to face about
why these things are hurting me and how
it's not personal and like this is
literally just about the safety of our
baby
and it's just gotten worse um and so i'm
just wondering
how how do i move on and like
be okay with that myself and
at least like be okay enough to help
them continue
to try to have a relationship with their
grandbaby
man you're not gonna this is so
frustrating man
this is i cannot stand it
when grown-ups act like children and i
cannot stand it
not even out of some trauma right just
because
we aren't getting our way right so if a
grown-up
throws a fit and they've got some stuff
from their past they're working through
some heavy stuff in their life i get it
man that happens
but when grown-ups just throw like a
like a this is a
my five-year-old doesn't throw these
fits anymore
and then they leave you the the new
person into the family
the mother of a small child trying to
figure out how you can best heal the
situation
a mess you didn't create
geez okay so a couple of questions how
how is your husband navigating this
sure so uh when the messages came
through
by the way good good good job grown-ups
i'm gonna i'm gonna text these really
hard things
because i'm so grown up i won't even
call you and say them to your face i'm
gonna
send them in a text message that'll that
way to go everybody all right continue
so uh he called his dad immediately and
was just like this is completely
out of line because your husband's a
grown-up good job
right he's like we make all of these
decisions together
this is my son i am his father like i'm
doing the best that i can
and we're both new parents this is our
first kid too dude look at your husband
man way to go
yeah so it's the first time that he's
kind of stood up to his parents and kind
of drawn that line
yeah and um so he's handling it like
like a champ he's he's doing amazing um
and
it sucks because now that now his
brother is
starting to get involved and calling him
and they had a big fight over the phone
about
all of this and stuff and so he he's
doing the best that he can in this
situation and he's amazing
yeah man i hate that for y'all all right
so here's here's the reality of your
situation
number one i'm gonna flip this whole
thing around okay
sure this is the this could not have
been a better situation for you guys
and here's why you're dealing with two
immature people and this was going to
come out
sooner rather than later it was going to
come out when your kid was spending a
week at their house
it was going to come out when they
didn't like the way you were
disciplining their their grandbaby right
as though that trump's year
um right like it was gonna come out and
it was gonna come out in a big
and bigger and bigger way the difference
now is
the kid isn't involved right the kid is
the proxy
for this power struggle but there's not
a five-year-old or a nine-year-old or a
13 year old downloading
their insights into how poor your
parenting is right
so where i'm telling you this is the
best thing that could have happened is
you got to let two people you have to
see their true colors
and now you get to build really firm
strong boundaries
this is in a weird way brought you and
your husband closer because you got to
watch him stand up for that
that that lady he loves right and you
always wondered if he would he did right
and he stood up to his parents into his
mama that's hard
man into his super aggressive texting
father
it's so ridiculous um so good for both
of you
now the reality this sucks right
this is not good this is not how you
drew it up of course you didn't want to
have a baby in the middle of a global
pandemic of course you didn't want to
have a baby
when you couldn't leave and go spend
time with your friends and family
of course you had these visions and
dreams of grandparents coming in and
being involved and all that's a mess
and then on top of that it's it's turned
silly
so what i'm going to tell you is this i
want you to
forget the relationship part you didn't
create that mess
you chose to respond to your baby in a
certain way and i want everyone to
listen to this
i'm not high-fiving her decision i
could care less what she chose to do the
reality is she
chose you and your husband chose
i'll call your husband bill how about
that nessa so nessa and
bill decided we have a new baby
these are the boundaries around our baby
and
bill's parents threw a temper tantrum it
doesn't matter what they
are i've had friends who are like hey
before you walk into my home you have to
do 30 push-ups and wash your hands and
get a colonic
and all the like dude i just want to
hang up and i've had other parents who
will just hand me your kid while i'm
mowing the yard and be like hey here you
go man
so every parent's different doesn't
matter they get to set the boundaries
because it's their kid
and so what i want you guys to do is
this you guys have now
seen a world where grandparents are
gonna act like children here's the deal
they're gonna come around
okay they just are and i want you guys
to not
lose your dignity don't lose your
character don't
lose who you are in order to make that
work
because that's never gonna work right
so you all get to decide you get to
decide
who you're going to be what kind of
boundaries you're going to have and
you're going to have to
create a new universe that doesn't
include his parents for a while until
they choose to grow up
and interact with their grandkids on
their terms and if brother wants to jump
in the mix
bro you're hurting mom's feelings
because but cool
then he gets to decide what he you know
he's making he's
he's crossing whatever line he wants to
cross right and all you're doing is
you guys drew boundaries and obviously a
boundary-free family
right and then people are gonna run up
and hit their head on those boundaries
and see if they hold
and now you guys just get to hold them
and it's lonely and isolating and
frustrating and annoying and you're
gonna weep you're gonna be sad and
you're gonna wonder what am i doing
wrong
what you're doing wrong is you're
deciding what kind of parent you want to
be
and you're sticking to it
i can't tell you anything magic that's
going to make them not immature
and i can't make anything tell you
anything magic that's going to make you
less frustrated at how they're
responding
you know what i mean i hate that for
y'all yeah no absolutely
not like i get it i get it so is there a
season where
um like let's say
in your immediate community the
restrictions are lifted your your
husband gets a text bill gets a text
here in a few weeks and says hey we both
got vaccinated we're both good
um we'd love to come see our grandkid
are you
poisoned now to that relationship or you
don't even want them around or
no are you gonna are you gonna welcome
them in
yeah no i've always welcome to welcome
them in i've always been the one to send
them the resources to
invite them to facetime call to do
whatever they can to connect with him
that's always coming from like me
mostly and so absolutely please come in
um i've i've kind of built up this
compartment
compartmentalization almost to where
their relationship with
our son is completely separate from
their relationship with me
and i try to get them involved in the
new milestones that he's
you know doing and you know i'm
extremely
the same like nice and kind and
you know all of that interaction's the
same so absolutely
um you gotta know nessa this is gonna
start over time to put a strain on your
marriage and i want you all to be
upfront and honest with each other
throughout this process okay
right yeah we um made an appointment for
marriage counseling to kind of come up
with a game plan
on how to navigate this moving forward
awesome
um yeah awesome and that's in the work
when you feel that first shard
that first little splinter of resentment
against your husband
because there's going to come a moment
when he's just going to say hey can we
just let him come by
right and can we like is there another
thing we can can we meet them halfway
if they all wear masks and they'll like
is there that's happened it's already
happened right okay
so when you start to see him
changing sides on you it's probably not
happening he's trying to find a middle
ground he may have met with a doctor he
may have and somebody said hey it's okay
for grandparents to hug your baby it's
okay
and and all that as you go through that
make sure when you start to feel like
he's switching teams on you
make sure you stop and pause and not in
an accusing way not now let's go to war
against u2 way but
say hey man i feel like we're switching
sides here is there something
you want to talk about tell me where
this is coming from right
and it's probably him doing the best he
can to not lose both his mom and dad and
his wife at the same time
right right and that's hard and
you i want you to commit to where you
feel like you can it sounds like you are
being
you've got really firm boundaries and
you're really you don't want those to
sever a relationship right you want
people to respect
who you are and where you are which i
think is great um
i also want you to always make sure you
are checking those boundaries
are they are they appropriate are they
right get somebody in your life i love
y'all going to see a marriage counselor
make sure those boundaries don't become
brick walls right if they become brick
walls and you end up walling yourself
in as much as you wall other people out
and so make sure
those boundaries when they're drawn
around medical issues or beliefs not
values but
they're drawn around beliefs man there's
some flexibility because at some point
you may read a new book you may have
your doctor may meet with your
child and they may say nah you're good
man you're good to let them hug whatever
those things are
so make sure that you are able to remain
peaceful and flexible but at the same
time
i'm proud of you for standing strong i'm
proud of you all for working hard on
this together and i'm proud of you all
for saying
ah we see a forest fire in the future
let's head down this road
and go meet with a marriage counselor
good for you
parents when you have grandkids
they are their kids first
then yours and i know you've been
waiting for this moment for so so so so
long
i know that you fill in the blank
they're not your kids they're not
and you remember back when people took
advantage of you and frustrated you and
said why you let them wear that why you
let them look like that and you know
it's annoying don't repeat that
i'll tell you what man i won the lottery
when it came to parents and
how they respect me and my wife our
boundaries with our kids it's it's
incredible
and i know i'm really fortunate and
privileged with that because not
everyone gets that so
thank you for that call nessa let me
know how that uh marriage counseling
session goes i'd love you to reach back
out and let me know how that goes y'all
working together to come up with a game
plan moving forward
and i'm grateful for the call all right
let's go to rachel in augusta georgia
rachel what's going on
hi dr john thank you so much for talking
with me ah thank you for calling what's
going on
uh well before i ask my question i just
wanted to say thank you for mentioning
the avett brothers
in multiple songs of the day because i
love the avett brothers so much
and it's just awesome hearing other
people talk about them i think they are
the
two best american songwriters working
today
i think they're extraordinary they have
a very special gift and they are wise
wise wise wise
brothers and i love them i love what
they're putting out in the world it's
awesome
yeah all right my question is so i teach
fifth grade
and i was wondering how i can give grace
to my kids my students
who i know are going through a lot with
the pandemic and
with school and we still have to do
state testing but still keep good
boundaries in classroom management
oh man are you are you my you're a plant
are you my son's teacher
i always maybe i'm always terrified that
my son's teacher's gonna call it and be
like
so what do you do when i have a student
who's terrible in class but their parent
has a really loud microphone and runs
his mouth all the time
so oh gosh i hope you're not really one
of my kids teachers are you
no okay good all right i thought kelly
was setting me up in here that would
have been real funny
all right so how do you set boundaries
how do you talk me through what you're
asking
so i i just don't want to be too hard on
them i don't
with all the things that they're going
through i still want to keep
you know a good relationship with them
and have good management but
i want to teach them responsibility but
i know they're going through a lot and i
don't want to be
too much gotcha i can speak to
i think that's going to be different
with every kid which is real frustrating
i can speak to the experience of my
fifth grader in my house
which is
there's that really fine balance but
it's important that accountability is so
important
and that teacher engagement is so
important and
wanting to make sure that he is a part
of something bigger than himself and so
the teachers
his teachers have just been
extraordinary in rallying that we're all
in this together
and when one of you all forgets your
homework or one of y'all just doesn't do
anything
it affects all of us we're all working
together on this thing
and at the same time man they have been
pretty flexible with
y'all go run around outside right we're
not gonna do seven hours of homework
after you've been in front of a computer
screen for seven hours too
pedagogically doesn't make sense just
like rationally that doesn't make sense
right
so there's been a really good balance
what are you seeing your students
struggle with um well we used to
have the kids switch classes um and but
now with
covid the teachers switch classes
there's three of us and so just
that personal responsibility of having
their stuff when they need to have it
they stay in the same room all day so
you would think it would be right there
but it just disappeared
it just disappears man it just goes away
i don't know where it goes rachel i
don't know where it goes i'll hand my
son something and it just evaporates
man um so specifically though besides
just losing a
so are you feeling bad about counting
off if they don't do an assignment
um yeah sometimes and like if they like
talking in the hallway
and things that they know they're not
supposed to do and i say quit talking
and then i give them
their warnings and they keep going and
they get financed and then
i i don't want them to go home and get
in trouble and not be able to go out and
run outside and
i just want them to be able to feel you
know comfortable
at school but not like every little
thing is going to get them in trouble
because
you know they can't go hang out with
their friends after school there they
can't do this
because of um pandemic so does that
really happen is that something you're
projecting out that might happen
um probably just me projecting okay okay
i don't know if you had a specific
situation
so i mean i love this question here's
why
i love moments when things get chaotic
and we have routines and we've got
rhythms and we've got the reason we do
things
and when things get chaotic when we
throw the rulebook out and just say i
don't know what to do next
i love it when folks take those moments
to get in a room
and say why are we still doing this why
are we still doing that
the alternative is we're just this is
the way we do it and this is where we're
gonna do it
and then all of a sudden you
incidentally start hurting people right
so let's take talking in the hallway for
example we got a group of kids that
can't play
they can run around outside right
limited
but they're not going to the movies
they're not fill in the blank right
they're with their parents that
social time has become an ability to
talk to somebody has become
a mental health lifeline for these young
kids
is there a larger pedagogical purpose
other than
we just want there to be silence in the
hallway could that be something that you
and your colleagues could say we're
going to let these kids talk
does that make sense and and it's just
that and then you go to the cafeteria
and then you go to
you know what we do 15 minutes of recess
let's do 45 let's just let them run and
run
and run and there is some science that
says if they get out move their body and
get some vitamin d i know it's been
winter but
they are gonna have some increase to
some
some um some raises in their academic
achievements right
um so rethinking some things at the same
time
recognizing man you guys gotta i cannot
believe these states haven't relaxed
some of this stuff but you guys still
got to hit those metrics right or you're
going to get docked as a bad teacher
so have you all had some of those
conversations can we release some of
this stuff and traded this for that
yeah i think we're kind of you know in
the war everything's always
in the works um you know they can't talk
it here they can't talk here they can't
talk here and we're trying to find ways
and places that they can talk and they
can be social
um it's just hard because we're a k-8
school and so man
and so there's a lot of things going on
all at the same time and we don't want
to disturb anybody but
yeah you know i try to give them i get i
call it talk time in class if they're
doing this they can have talk time but
they also have to have their mask on and
you know farther away from each other
and it makes it
it's so much fun so here's here's one of
my
one of my if i distill it all down we
and you and i man i love talking about
classroom management and i really love
talking about the flow of how schools
are administrated
um i think some people do it
extraordinary and some people
i don't even know if they would i don't
even know what program they could have
graduated from for how they run stuff
i think at the end of the day i want to
free your heart and let you know that
accountability
done in a loving connected context is a
good thing for kids
they crave those boundaries and when
everything feels chaotic because a covet
their parents are heightened
their parents are fighting more we're
watching the seo data
people all over the country are um all
over the world
are searching into google how do i know
my relationship's over when do i know to
get divorced right
we know that the i met with some
counselors last night i had dinner from
texas
and talking about the increases in abuse
at home
the increase in anger outbursts at home
so we know these kids are going through
at home
what they and then they come to school
and they crave
being seen and they crave safety
and safety comes from that
accountability right
and that's different than yelling and
being arbitrary and screaming et cetera
so with a fifth grade class they're old
enough i would explain
why like hallway traffic at a k-8 school
is at a premium right and if we're
allowed it affects them
and maybe you might change your outcomes
maybe i love that you're giving them
talk time you give them whatever
you're you are ringing
and connection out of this madness that
we were in
and whatever group of fifth graders have
you as their teacher has won
the lottery they are so lucky to have
you uh rachel it's really extraordinary
what you're trying to do for those kids
i don't want to see us just take all the
fences down and say y'all run them up
because i know it's hard and so y'all
just run chaotic because that's going to
add to the stress and anxiety and
depression of these kids
so boundaries are good holding kids
accountable is good
my son had a homework assignment
evaporate the other day
and his teacher called him out in front
of the whole class and he came home and
said i let my teacher down i should have
got my homework and we talked through it
but here's the thing i'm glad that a
teacher has some accountability
i am just saying well i know things are
hard you don't have to do anything it's
cool
um they're going to get enough of that
when they're adults right
um and we're watching grown-ups act like
children right now
into all of this right so i think
accountability is good connection and
compassion is good and
let those kids know this one thing you
as their teacher
love them use your teacher see them
and however you can i know you can't hug
kids anymore
but you can get down and let them see
you eye to eye and you can smile
and they can see your eye crinkles and
you can say those magic words i see you
i'm so glad you're here and that works
with high school
kids by the way tough guy high school
teachers
you can look at a high school kid who's
acting all hardcore and you can stop and
go hey
i'm so glad you're here i see you i'm
glad you're in this chemistry class you
don't ever turn anything in
but i'm glad you're here hey fifth
grader i'm so glad you're here
we're all turning our homework in we all
are turning in our worksheets nobody's
gonna miss
we're gonna help each other get it done
we're gonna encourage each other to get
done but we're all in this together
and so i that's that's the best i can
tell you without spending an hour
talking about
classroom management stuff um but i love
love love your heart
and man hold those kids accountable and
let them be seen
all right um let's get into some
dangerous territory here one of the
questions i get asked all the time
is am i getting the coven 19 vaccine
right
so here's the deal i'm going to tell you
what i'm going to do but i want to talk
about the process first because i think
the process
is important for making this decision
any kind of decision right
one of my life philosophies is to always
have
an expert like do you know a guy do you
know a gal
do you know a person who knows something
about this thing
right and this is the deal
i'm not that smart i went to a lot of
school and i studied a couple of things
really deeply
but i'm not that smart the thing i'm
most smart about
is what i don't know right which is a
lot
plumbing no idea i got a guy cable
barrett
right i mean bear cable barrett cable
his name is barrett cable not cable
barrett
building how to build something i'm
embarrassing i'm humil
i am i am shameful at how i can try to
build stuff
but lucky i got a guy charlie turner
winston cruz
i know guys who know guys right legal
scholarship right how do i
interpret a new legal ruling i could go
to the internets
and it's going to give me a bunch of
nonsense headlines and drama
nope i got rob cassie tracy alex darby
dustin
i got folks that i call because i'm not
a legal scholar
i don't know banking todd uh
funny memes plus and caleb investments
chris hogan my buddy craig swann right
education my wife the other the doctor
sheila deloney
dr mark phillips dr stephanie talley
trucks anything trucks i call my buddy
michael
internet things kevin right counseling
dr
janet dr lin dr steve dr brett dr aretha
et cetera et cetera here's the thing
we are the worst at being honest about
what we don't know
we have tons of opinions but very little
knowledge
we read a headline we watch a youtube
clip and we consider ourselves
experts right worse we form an opinion
something that we really want to be true
or we hear something and we think that's
not right
and we go searching for anyone on the
internets
anyone to back us up right
and here's the thing you can go down a
rabbit hole
and you will find some dude in the back
of his car in the trunk
recording a youtube show with 11
followers
and they will he will come up with the
thing that you think
right so back to the cova vaccine when
it comes to the science of vaccines
i don't know and i know a lot about
science i know a lot about research
about biology i don't know about
vaccines i'm not an epidemiologist
i'm not a research biologist or a
virologist
and you aren't either right
and i misjudged this thing out of the
gate big time
so i called my friend who's the dean of
a pharmacy school
a good pharmacy school he's a close
buddy he's brilliant he's a research
scholar
and so i called him and i said hey what
do you think man are you getting this
this vaccine and he said man i read the
science
um it's better than i could have ever
dreamt
and so me and my family yeah we're for
sure getting it i'll be first in line
i'll be
i'll get as soon as they're allowed me
and my first thought was ah
sucker dean of a pharmacy school you're
in bed with big pharma i knew it
i knew it right so i called the chair of
a biology by the way
he's a good friend and i think i said
that exact thing to his face so
um that i called the chair of a biology
department a cancer researcher at
another university
right i changed college universities
changed genders
stupid guys i'm gonna call a brilliant
woman cancer researcher
said hey you getting this vaccine and
she told me the science was so
impressive
so much more impressive than she could
have thought the vaccines really aren't
that complicated
she was part of the trial and things
have been great
i said you that's ridiculous so i called
my minister
and that sucker was part of a trial too
and i just thought i'm being
failed by everybody everyone i needed
you to back up my opinion
i knew somebody close friend i've known
her for almost 30 years oh my gosh i'm
getting old i've done it forever
i called her she's a homeopathic doctor
i've got you vaccinators now
uh hey this is even better a homeopathic
doctor on the west coast
booyah called her we talked for a long
time about the science
she's a brilliant researcher
practitioner and she said this is
causing a ton of challenges
but i'll get it as soon as i'm able i'm
gonna sign up and get it
so i asked three different experts
plus a minister hey what's the deal on
this deal and
they said not only are we doing it but
we would give it to our families
i'll be first in line my medical friends
they did it so here's the thing
when it comes to medical advice
psychological advice etc please go into
these things with an open
mind don't try to find somebody to back
up your opinion
because there are a billion people
trying to just put their nonsense their
opinion their attitude
some scandalous conspiracy theory out
there right
so am i getting the vaccine yeah for
sure because i don't know enough about
it
but i do know four people who i trust
deeply
have said yeah this is something we're
doing for ourselves
if it was available for our kids and the
research meets our kids which it hasn't
yet we would do that too
but there's not been research on kids so
we're not there yet i trust them
when it comes to getting on internets
right i trust
dr tia dr rhonda patrick robert
zaplowski
gabor mate right ben greenfield because
of their longevity
they're researched back understanding
their personal experiences
right i got two phds i've years of
working with folks and i'm not afraid to
say this magic thing
i was wrong and all those people i just
mentioned they've said the phrase
man i was wrong too i had to rethink
this thing
things change i learn more i'm growing
right
so i trust folks but i put a lot of
energy into trusting
figuring out why i should trust them and
it's because of their expertise
sometimes because of their education
sometimes because of their experience
sometimes because they've been in this
thing for a long time sometimes because
they'll say the words i was wrong
i misjudged this i got new information
so i changed what i understood
and they are humble and more importantly
they do these things with themselves
they do these things with their kids
and when i i can ask somebody all day
long hey
um what do you think and they're going
to give me a dissertation
but then i ask them hey what are you
doing with your kids and they'll say
yeah what are you doing with yourself do
you actually take this supplement
do you actually plan on getting a line
to get that vaccine and they'll say yeah
i did
so i'm going to because the folks who
know more have said it's a great idea
and if i'm wrong and this is a massive
money grab and we all die
here's the thing i don't want to live in
a world where all the doctors and
surgeons and nurses and leaders and
teachers and social workers and mental
health professionals where they've all
died anyway so
there we go i'm ready to go too so
that's my thought on the covenant team
vaccine but more importantly than that
that's how i go about solving some of
these problems i
don't default to my opinion my bad
attitude
some conspiracy theory or some angry
person on the internet
i try to get deeper than that and go to
experts who know
what they're talking about right all
right so let's go to mitchell
hey mitchell what's up brother so my
fiance is an icu nurse and uh she's been
dealing with the worst side of the
pandemic here
yeah she loves her job yeah she loves
her job but i can see it's taking a toll
on her spirit and it's just you know
emotionally draining
um we talk every day when she comes home
when she comes home from work but
you know aside from listening what else
can i be doing to support her
emotionally and just spiritually man
dude i'm i'm so grateful for you
mitchell
thank you for your heart and for being
one of those guys that
wants to love your wife the best way you
know how
so when she comes home give everybody a
penis a picture of what life is like
when she gets home
she walks through the door then what
sure um i would say
you know it's every other day it's a
pretty sad day she'll lose a patient or
two
um and it's when they lose covet
patients in the icu
you know families don't get to go say
bye she has to be the one
hold the ipad and hold that patient's
hand um
when they leave this earth so she
carries that you know she carries that
burden
um i can see that on her shoulders and i
feel
a little helpless because i can't
relieve that for her yeah
enough hey nothing's worse than
watching somebody you love hurt and
and you can't be the one that heals that
right
yep it hurts it's hard man um and
you alluded to it i just i'll go one
step further
and i know this is a little bit graphic
but when somebody gets to a place where
they're in their time has come and
they're they're being propped up by
machines
and the doctor says it's time it's the
nurse
that reaches down and turns the machines
off that pulls
the proverbial plug that pulls the tubes
out that actually
pulls the lifeline out of somebody's
vein
and if you if if and i know you know
this mitchell because you know this
acutely but
for those of you who don't know nurses
carry that around with them i'm the one
the doctor made the declaration but i'm
the one that turned the switch
i'm the one that pulled that too and
you want to talk about carrying some
weight right
it is a weight that very very few people
will ever ever
i'll never understand that right that's
a weight so
she comes home and she talks to you tell
me how those conversations go how do
they
paint us a picture of it is it in your
bedroom is it in the living room y'all
have kids tell me tell me what that
looks like
yeah we don't have kids um we're
actually about to so it's not my wife
yet but we're about to be married in
about a month here
okay um you know oh yeah okay yeah
yeah um it's sometimes on the couch
um if it's a very heavy day
um it's one of those where you know we
sit down across the table from each
other and
we'll talk about it and talk about it
face to face
those are the heaviest days because you
know really all my attention needs to be
in that and
you know just listening to her there are
you a therapist man
i'm not well what do you do for a living
um i'm in customer success i work in you
know
tech if you will so i mean i i hope i i
listened for a living
i was gonna say man she won the lottery
with you brother
i wish i had had you as a friend talking
about knowing experts i wish i had known
you when i first got
married so long ago because you would
have told me stop talking
stop talking and just listen right
you're a great friend to have
so here's a couple of things you can do
number one you were already there
knowing i can't fix this
most spouses want to fix it
and what that does number one is it
turns their partner into a machine
which they're not right it turns them
into something that is quote unquote
broken
which she's not but she does need to
process sadness
she does need to process that isolating
feeling you get when you turn
a switch and somebody's life ends
even if it's the right humane thing
or when you stop a ventilator or fill in
the blank
man that is lonely in a world that no
one can understand that kind of
loneliness right you can't solve that
but she's not broken right she's
processing this and feeling this and
experiencing this so
here's a couple of things you can do
number one
i'm you don't do this and so i'm
speaking this into existence for other
folks who are listening
ask somebody how you can best love them
don't try to love them the best way you
know how
often folks try to love each other with
the only tools they have right which is
maybe physical touch maybe buying a
bunch of gifts maybe giving a bunch of
advice
and if that's not how somebody else
feels loved it ends up crushing them
right because they then try to have to
also have the burden of making you feel
good about
the gift that they don't want or that's
burning them but they know you're doing
it with a good spirit right
so just ask the question when she's
sitting across the table from you
reach your hands out when she touch when
she's talking to you if you can
if she will is able to touch you when
she does that there's a processing
um that happens when you have physical
touch and you're talking to somebody
that makes it very visceral very real
if she'll reach across that table and
hold your hand while she's talking to
you it'd be awesome
and when she gets done ask her those
words out loud
how can i best love you right now just
ask her hey how can i best love you
right now right
the second thing is what are things that
wear her out
and i'm taking emily nagaski's language
what are some of her offs
not just you know in the bedroom right
but what are some offs things that she
hates doing
and it could be filling the car up with
gas for years my wife hated getting gas
and so it was just a big deal
on sunday nights i just go fill her car
right things like that what are
what are things that drive her bananas
about the world that you could take from
her and lighten her load
i mean the easy one for us is laundry
that
that never goes away yeah man
it's a burden for us you know we vote we
do work uh
full time and you know at the end of the
week it'll just be a mountain and we're
like where did that even come from
yes and it grows right that's how we
spend our weekend
you know just doing chores because we're
working through the week um
so yeah laundry and dishes so i would
say the normal household you know she
she's exhausted when she comes home so
that's not something we want to do
do you have a laundry like a washer
dryer inside your place
we do okay so this is something i
started as part of my morning routine a
few weeks ago i'm just giving it a shot
and it has been
it's one of those moments things has
pushed me into like a shame cycle
because of how easy it is
and that is in the morning when i wake
up i just go switch one load of laundry
i'm trying to squeeze in one thing of
service a day just one
right and it's best in the morning for
my kids are awake
and i can just move one thing from the
washer to the dryer and the dryer out
and i fold it and i can set it there and
go hang it up it takes
five minutes max five minutes but
usually three
and then it's over and then on saturday
we don't get this insane pile that grows
up
does that make sense so there's these
little ways to begin to chip away at
that
in a problem-solving way but think
through those things i know you're tired
too
but what are those things you can give
to her in this season of chaos
that's going to be a gift to your entire
family unit you're holding her arms up
in the desert right now when she's
exhausted and there will come a season
in your relationship when she'll hold
yours up right
but right now this is that moment for
y'all what find some things that just
are a burden to her
and see if you can take those from her
you're adding onto your plate you don't
have any space and i get that
but she's in a season of crisis and so
i'm asking you to step into those
moments right
so the third thing is you said you'll
have a debrief time
here's something that may not work for
every couple this is just an idea
if you guys have a gratitude journal
where
here but it's gonna be a unique one i
want you to go buy a journal and buy
something fancy pants
and set it in a place where she can see
it right
whether that's on on the bed at night
at a place where she sits down and reads
but i want you to write three or four
things that start with i'm grateful for
her and write it out right and they can
be the same thing sometimes
leave it in a place where she's gonna
see it and ask her
if she will take a moment or two a day
to write out some things she experienced
that day
and what i want her to begin to do is
associate your
continued gratitude for her she's not a
burden to you
she is the joy of your life you're about
to commit to spend the rest of your life
with her forever and ever amen
and i want to give her a space to begin
to write some of this stuff out and get
it out of her head
right and so it's a it's a multi-tier
task she may say i'm not writing
anything but i'll
i'll read your gratitude journal she may
take your gratitude and throw it on the
floor like i'm not reading that right
now
you keep doing it keep doing it because
here's why after
two months of doing laundry and doing
all the stuff in the dishes all by
yourself you're gonna start getting
resentful and exhausted too because
you're working a full-time job right
you're not doing these together anymore
you just picked up all the slack
i want you to be reminding yourself i'm
grateful for her man i am grateful for
her
and i want her to see the daily
decisions you're making to love her
and over time she's going to love
herself bonus if she'll
write it down okay now here's the last
thing i want y'all to do
every morning before you guys leave for
work i want you to hold her hands and
look her in the eye
and say i love you and
what does your picture of today look
like what do you got on your plate
not hey how can i serve you because now
she's got to come up with a bunch of
reasons why she's
what are what does your picture look
like for today
just giving an architecture providing
architecture for the day for the both of
you
is freeing right and then it allows her
to go in and do the hard hard work that
she's got to do
and then she can circle out come home be
fully herself sit at that table and look
at the guy she loves and just says
and say well this happened today and you
can hold their hands look in the eye and
say
i hate that for you i'm so so sorry i'm
so so sorry how can i love you right now
and then in the morning oh my gosh
what's the picture of today going to
look like
what's it gonna look like today i'm
gonna do one i'm gonna sneak one i'm
gonna sneak two
little acts of service throughout the
day so that on saturday or sunday
our days can be going for walks can be
going outside
she can take some quiet time she can
have some journaling time give her some
of that space that she desperately needs
to process this trauma that she's
experiencing right
it's a lot it's a lot it's a lot but
first and foremost mitchell thank you so
much for your heart and for your soul
so grateful for you brother so grateful
all right so as we wrap up today's covet
show man
everybody's experiencing this in some
shape form or fashion this is messed up
relationships this is messed up work
places this is messed up
parenting teaching nurse all of it
be graceful with one another be graceful
for people who are doing things
differently than you
don't assume that everyone's a jerk and
don't assume that everyone knows as much
as you do
don't assume that everyone just hasn't
watched the one youtube clip you have
don't assume that fill in the blank
assume that everyone's doing the best
they can with the limited tools they
have
be kind and be graceful if somebody's
really frustrating you
take them to a place where you can they
can retain their dignity take they can
they can retain their respect and you
can say hey here's how we're going to do
it here
right and continue to work together to
be conscious and kind
and do the things you can do in your
little sphere of control
to give yourself peace to give yourself
um the next right step
and don't forget to feel sad don't
forget to be lonely don't forget to be
frustrated those are all real feelings
and
angry all that's real all of it's real
give yourself permission to feel those
things and then go do the next right
thing so to wrap up today's show
let's see here man james do you want to
go 1988 or 1995.
88 no question 88 no question when you
were born
no but you don't need to know when i was
i don't need to know that it's part of
he's it's off the grid baby
all right so man this the greatest
rap hip-hop group of all time no
question about it
the originals they're the originals
before the originals
in 1998 they came out with an
extraordinary record called it takes a
nation of millions to hold us back
public enemy in 1988 dropped one of my
favorite songs of all time
called bring the noise and it goes
like this bass hello can you go
death row would a brother know once
again back is the incredible
the rhyme animal the uncannible d public
enemy number one
5.0 said freeze and i got numb can i
tell them that i never
really had a gun but it's the wax at the
terminator x fun
now they got me in a cell because my
records records they sell because a
brother like me said well
farrakhan's a prophet and i think you
ought to listen to what can he say to
you
what you ought to do is follow for now
power of the people say
make a miracle d pump the lyrical dude
this song is so good
listen to it and they joined anthrax for
the greatest live song i've ever seen
bring the noise public enemy
from coast to coast i i could go all day
but i'm not going to this has been the
dr john dolone's show
you